[Music]
let's go out to Kate in Philadelphia we
born and raised what's up Kate hey Dr
John how are you we're doing good how
about you doing well thank you so much
and just a huge thanks to you guys and
your team I'm really grateful for your
show thank you I'm glad that you are in
our gang man it's awesome to have you
what's
up well I am a little embarrassed
slightly nervous I have a weird question
hopefully it's normal but um I'm a
person who I talk to myself a lot and
most of the time not most of the time
some of the time it's in my head some of
the time it's out
loud and I don't really realize I'm
doing it until I'm already talking out
loud and it's it can be embarrassing
when I'm around other people and not
really realizing it until it's already
happening and so I don't know if that's
normal or what I can do to help that or
you know it's just it's a thing that
happens in my world and was like like ah
I need some help with this yeah I mean
there's there's a lot of things to pull
apart here I
I I don't I don't like thinking in terms
of is this normal or not there's a bell
curve right there's this idea that given
a 100 people 85 of them will do x on a
regular basis semi-regular basis and
seven over here we'll do this and eight
over here like I get that um I like to
think of these kind of things more in
terms of I'm assuming that the talk you
you're talking is not
nice um yeah probably not all right so
if you were just like talking about your
grocery list out loud that I can't
imagine that would cause you a lot of
stress my guess is you are pretty mean
to yourself and occasionally you find
yourself talking out loud like God you
suck you idiot like right and you're
finding yourself in a public space kind
of and people are like who are you so
angry at is that more like
yeah yeah I think it's it's a
combination of that and then it's also
like moments when I felt embarrassed
about something that I did or behavior
or like conversations that I should have
or things that I should have said and
conversations I had with other people
you know that type of thing yes uh the
rumination we love it totally if you
just think about it enough you can
actually go back in time and change what
happened so yes I figur that might be
keep doing that all right so
um I like to think of it instead of is
this normal or not normal as my body
chooses to deal with uncomfortable
situations like
this and I would like to teach it a
different way of handling it period okay
and one of those is I can't believe I'm
so not normal this is so weird and then
your body like just saying that my
shoulders went up around my ears a
little bit and I got a little tint
saying I'm not normal I got to fix this
versus ah my body handles stress like
this and I don't like it and so I want
to do something different one of those
is infinitely more compassionate and
curiosity driven and one is more
judgmental you stupid you start in
a hole on one of them right um have you
ever been diagnosed with um
OCD um no I've never been a formally
diagnosed with anything but I would not
surprise me I guess tell me about tell
me about your ruminating
thoughts yeah um um it's a good it's
it's pretty broad I kind of ruminate a
lot on a lot of different topics okay
but um I think you know if it's it's
kind of a cute stressors right so if I
have a a negative interaction with
someone at work I do a lot of management
of people and personalities and so if I
have a negative interaction at work I'll
kind of ruminate on that conversation
and what I could have done better or you
know just sort of um any of any aspect
of that um and you know any any other
sort of I guess interaction with people
or scenarios where I wish I would have
done something different um but why do
you wish you would have done something
different where does that like I'm
trying to drill down to the Judgment
part why do you wish that's fair like
when you say I was it's so embarrassing
to who yeah that people actually comment
to you or no they no because they're
staring in their own weird world that's
fair um I think it's it's yeah I think
it's mostly my own stuff I think there's
certainly some Personalities in my life
um that you know will no matter sort of
have a their own personal view of me
which I obviously also cannot control
but um you know I just I know that
theyve used they view me through a
certain lens and so I just it makes me
frustrated and you know but um for the
most part it's just my own self judgment
for sure so why don't you like
you that's a great question I think I
really do like me there's you know um
I've done a lot of self-work and you
know really spent the last decade or so
learning how to love myself and so
that's been great but it's still you
know always a work in progress um I
think it's just have you learned to love
yourself or have you learned
to
um um act
right yeah I there's 100% a factor of
that um you know I definitely know that
there's certain ways to be um but I
think it's a combination of both like I
said I think it's still a work in
progress for me and that sort of self AC
Acceptance in those moments where it's
you know where I am ruminating and
thinking gosh I wish I would have some
done something differently there's also
that quiet quiet tur voice but that's
saying you know no you're normal you're
this is you're human um everybody messes
up or you know it's there's no such
thing as perfect right so that that is a
small voice in the head as well but all
right I'm gonna give you a couple of
tools that I think can transform your
whole life okay okay for real yeah um
I'm gonna write down a quick note to
myself
all right so um that way I don't forget
it I want you to internalize this with
all of your might okay rumination is a
complete and utter waste of your time
yeah okay and so here's the problem
rumination feels like important thinking
helpful thinking yeah okay right it
feels like we are replaying this thing
and next time we're gonna fill in the
blank right problem is we never get to
the next time we get to the what we did
wrong why we suck why we could have done
it better and then we just park in that
just swimming pool of shame we just sit
in it m yes sir so there's a difference
between rumination and reflection
reflection is a critically important
part of being a healthy human and
reflection is simply a it's got It's
this it's about looking to the past the
good and the bad likes and dislikes and
then tangibly planning for how things
are going to be different in the
future okay for instance like
um I had a meeting with my boss I man I
was awkward I started stuttering and
then when I started stuttering I started
speaking really fast and I wasn't fully
prepared that was
annoying so next time I have a meeting
with the boss I'm going to be very uh
prepared okay that's
reflection um rumination is I can't
believe that he right now he's sitting
at home thinking I can't believe I hired
this freaking I got to find a new
person and and your body goes to War it
goes to fight or flight you know why
because it thinks it's about to get
fired or it thinks it's about to not
have a home or a car or
food and so you start spinning up I
should have said this I'm gonna tell
them this thing you couldn't tell them
this thing because you're an idiot and
it's just this it's a it's a chorus of
voices yelling at you that sound like
one United voice that's a total complete
waste of your time rumination is trying
to change something in the past by going
over it and over it and over it and over
it again or it's trying to change
something in the future that hasn't even
happened
yet right it's a waste of time it's like
it's practice Bernay Brown calls it
dress rehearsing
tragedy right so how do you stop it in
that moment where you say when you're
trying to be more reflective reflective
as opposed to
ruminating when you say for example to
use your example you know I had a bad
meeting with my boss and I want to do
this differently next time I'm going to
be better prepared next time how do you
like because when I think through that
process my body then immediately goes
into the next step which is the shame
process you know all that and so how do
you stop your body in that moment to
just I don't think it there and let it
go I don't think it does I think when
you sit down and go man that was not a
good meeting I wasn't
prepared and you and I'm going to give
you a the the ultimate trick here in a
second and it's not a hack but or a
trick but it is it's neuroscience and
it's magic um okay but there's a
difference between saying that did not
go like I wanted it to I feel bad about
how it went I feel sad I feel ashamed of
how I I acted in that meeting that's
fair that's fair I'm gonna let my body
feel that because that's right and then
I'm GNA pull out a piece of paper I
carry a note card with me or I've got my
little my little journal with me I'm
gonna make sure next time I'm going to
do X Y and Z I make a plan and it's very
short and then I'm moving on okay it's
the
rumination it's the when you start
creating stories on top of the story
right and well I wasn't prepared well I
can't be prepared if the boss is always
making me also do all these other things
and by the way Jenny never does her work
and so I've got to do hers too so of
course I don't have time now we're in
fight or flight now your body's pulsing
with cortisol and adrenaline it is not
thinking clearly it is in survival mode
right and I feel like it's unstopped
like it feels like it's a train that
can't be stopped when it starts you know
and it almost feels like I come out of a
a days right W up afterwards yeah so
every um Peter lavine's done some some
really Exquisite work on
this that fight ORF flight is designed
to run from a tiger or to fight a tiger
or to try to kill somebody who's
stealing your mate right or your child
yeah and so it pumps your body full of
these chemicals and in our modern world
we just
go and then we type an email response
right and so that days you're talking
about is it's biochemical it's
real the only way to I found to cycle
out of it is to go for I go rucking I
put some weights in a heavy backpack a g
rock bag and take off down the road or I
go for a walk I've got some rules now in
my personal life I don't respond to
things while I'm engaged while I'm mad
while I'm frustrated because it's I'm
not thinking rationally at all at all
right so yes that coming out of that
days you're exactly right your body's
got to metabolize that stress
response oh that's why every major uh
religion has a or culture has dances as
a part of it tribal movements as a part
of it because it your body knows hey we
just had a fight orfl flight situation
and we
survived let's all celebrate this thing
together see what I'm saying you're not
crazy now I'm going to give you um
something that has been transformative
for me and I want you to read this book
it's by Ethan cross k r o SS and the
book is called
chatter okay and last I looked he was at
University of Michigan he um studies
that voice in your head that never shuts
up okay and it's a tool I took from him
that has been Transcendent for
me and here's the idea there is a neural
pathway for I for
me and there is a different neural
pathway for you y'all so think about
about this one of your employees comes
to you and says hey my marriage is
falling apart and I did this thing I
don't know what to do
next you very clearly can go well Dan
you should fill in the
blank and your body doesn't get
activated doesn't run off into the
woods but when you think I screwed up my
marriage I did this I'm a piece of
whatever and I now your body's got to
defend itself because it's at War right
right so what Dr cross suggests is begin
talking to yourself in the third
person and he gave some examples in the
book about um you you hear interviews
with
athletes and they'll say like LeBron
James will be being interviewed who'll
be like well LeBron on that Court LeBron
James
decides and I you know most of us roll
our eyes at that what he has suggesting
is no no no no that is a different
person that is a that is a person who
takes shots that's a person who misses
shots that's the kind of person who does
this kind of
work so what I've started doing is
saying
um here's a good example somebody hit my
car while I was in it the other day a
woman was coming to her fancy BMW right
parked right next to me I just pulled in
I was meeting my my wife and daughter
for a movie and this woman opens we made
eye contact as she opened her door and
just bammed my car door and then she
kind of like made like a huh
and got in her car and her husband was
with her and a teenage son was with her
and dude I'm telling you I was it was
the holidays I was tired I've been
traveling I went full Defcon I was
enraged and I got out of the car and
looked at the dent and I looked at her
and she rolled down the window and goes
what did I do something and I said yes
you hit my car we both watched you hit
my car and then she goes uh and I said
look and there there was a sizable Dent
Kate and she said I didn't do that I was
distracted I I I was I was distracted as
though and here's the thing I was just
thinking in my head just say sorry it's
a stupid car I don't care just say
sorry and then I happened to glance back
and her son is it her teenage son he was
big he's big boy he's like my
size and he looked ashamed for his
mom and in that moment I locked the car
door and I said to myself John walk
away because if somebody had come up to
me on the street and said hey this lady
in this car doings your car and she's
hollering it's about to cause a
situation and she's got embarrassed I
would say dude just walk away it's a D
in your car
right John though wants husband to get
out of the car and me and him are going
to settle us the parking lot right and I
want your insurance and you're replacing
my whole door panel and I had a right to
that I have a legal right to have a new
door panel
but when I talk to John I would say dude
just walk away your daughter's in there
you'reall going to watch a movie
together youall have a daddy daughter
date go see what I'm saying yeah and so
talking to John I stay present because I
treat other people way nicer than I
treat myself totally right so I want you
to practice Kate writing these things
down get them out of your head okay
number one number two you've probably
heard me talk about this on the show
maybe it's been a while I often I don't
do it much anymore but I used to do all
the time when I was trying to break this
bad habit I would yell in my house no
real
loud and what I was doing was I was
stopping the imaginary conversations
that I was having all the time right I
just stop it I'm gonna break it I'm
gonna go no as soon as I remember it
soon as I realize I'm doing this nope
nope nope my wife would just roll her
eyes she would just be like oh my gosh
my husband's talking to himself again
and I would break it and then I would
say to myself
this has no
value right
none yeah okay then I would ask myself
do I need to do something different
that's it and here it is your body is
simply responding to the stress of your
life by replaying things over and over
again and ultimately that leaks out into
you talking to yourself in some pretty
ugly
ways and you just have to decide I want
to teach my body a different way of
dealing with stress right and I'm going
to practice that and then the third
thing I want you to do start talking to
yourself in the third
person okay Kate had a conversation with
the boss it didn't go well well Kate
what'd you learn I need to be more
prepared all right next time Kate you're
gonna be more
prepared that is such a different
conversation then I suck I screwed it up
again and then when Kate says but I
always mess this up and you're like yeah
Kate you've messed up a bunch but from
now on you're not gonna mess up anymore
and here's what K Kate here's what we're
gonna do you see what I'm saying
I do yeah I do and I can't wrap my head
around how much how big of a difference
it makes by creating this psychological
distance between me
and my threat response system it's
pretty profound I may see if we can get
Ethan cross on the show I'd love for him
if he's in Nashville I'd love for him to
be on the show Dr cross if you're here
join the show that'd be awesome um but
that particular piece of his work has
been really important for
me cuz again I treat other people so
much nicer than I treat myself so if I
start talking to myself with some space
it allows me to make errors allows me to
be forgiving allows me to be curious
John why'd you just get mad at your
eight-year-old daughter she's
eight well because of this and this well
maybe you should just not eat that maybe
you should get some sleep and maybe you
should go tell your daughter you're
sorry that's different than I suck at
being a dad and I'm the worst and I N so
try it try it it's it's it's
Neuroscience it's not just woow woo um
but give it a whir grateful for you Kate
call
anytime